and finally new rule conservatives can
blame liberals for a lot of things like
making your kid wear a bike helmet and
gluten-free cupcakes and the war on
Christmas but the one thing you're not
going to get to blame us for is Donald
Trump because they are already trying to
do that but it is not going to happen if
we have to own the man bun you have to
own the Donald
if you think I'm kidding about this or
exaggerating just look at some of these
recent Internet headlines the left is to
blame for the creation of Donald Trump
how the PC police propelled Donald Trump
how the left created Donald Trump update
your browser milks in your area needs
sex now no wait not that one I'm sorry
but others other than that one the
points of all these think pieces is that
the Trump phenomenon is on you liberals
because your condescension and political
correctness forced otherwise reasonable
people into Trump's eight full embrace
that is their thesis really that Trump
voters are perfectly nice if left alone
like raccoons hey they just want to eat
garbage and crap in your hot tub
honey booboo and the duck commander are
Adam and Eve at the Olive Garden and
they would vote rationally if not for
overbearing liberal scientists and
historians and nutritionists telling
real Americans that they're dumb it
hurts their feelings when we insult
their values with our facts
listen a voxcom they say liberals are
smug because we practice quote a
politics defined by the command of
correct facts
well yeah shouldn't we all do that
the Daily Beast's claims that brutish
leftist tactics have driven people to
trump because they're terrified that
they're losing the basic right to
express themselves really have you seen
the Internet it's nothing but angry
white people expressing themselves the
Tea Party is named after a tax revolt
and T stands for taxed enough already
and yet two years after Obama lowered
taxes on 95 percent of Americans 90
percent of T people believed he'd raised
them so if you don't know the first
thing about the thing you claim is the
most important thing to you
are you bright
is it my fault for pointing out no the
Federalist says voters like Donald Trump
not so much because they hate Mexicans
and Muslims but because they hate
progressive bigotry no it's because they
hate Muslims in Mexico among other
minorities 64% of Republicans think
reverse racism is a greater problem than
racism now that is something easily
disproved with statistics so please help
me with my dilemma of how I as a liberal
fact knower can both not insult you but
also tell the truth because like I can't
honestly say I respect your view that
the world is 5,000 years old because
it's 2016 if Sarah Palin claims
nighttime is when Jesus puts a blanket
over the Sun and I disagree does that
make me smug I'm sorry you find it
irritating when liberals point out that
global warming exists or that racism
exists or that gay people exist but
here's the thing you guys were wrong the
ball about all that really check the
climate science check the dashboard
camera on the police car check your
pastor's internet history
now is political correctness out of
control
of course it is I think I might have
done some sort of show about that but
I've been telling liberals when they had
spinach on their teeth since 1993
I've ridiculed them for everything from
offensive Halloween costumes to
Islamophobia from the self-esteem
movement to college campuses forgetting
what free speech is but none of that
justifies embracing a dangerous buffoon
simply because his lack of political
correctness is cathartic Trump is your
problem but somehow the party of
personal responsibility doesn't want to
take responsibility for this one
somewhere along the way the slogan went
from make America great again to look
what you made me do